these numbers come as december marks the
deadliest month for kobit 19 in our
state so far
and now now marks conarona virus
nevada's leading cause of death
the i-team's david charns is live in the
newsroom with more details for us all
new here at four o'clock david and
denise nearly 700 nevadans have died
this month alone from coronavirus and of
course december is not over with 697
cova deaths this month
covid now outpacing heart disease as the
leading cause of death here in nevada
but just
for december remember though coven 19 is
a virus
it's contagious the top other causes of
death
cardiovascular diseases stroke diabetes
you can't catch that from somebody else
and right now health leaders say we are
seeing a slight dip in cases
not because a lack of spread but because
of lack of testing
we've been reporting pretty low numbers
of new cases and
general testing but we really do think
that that's a result of people not
getting tested on christmas day and
probably
folks that do get sick as a result of
the holiday or
get sick around that time will be
seeking testing in the next week or so
nevada's test positivity rate remaining
the second highest in our country as of
last week
that is according to a document obtained
by the center for public
public integrity comes from the white
house coronavirus task force
20 percent of tests are coming back
positive for covet
now health officials remain concerned
about christmas and the new year now
less than 48 hours away new year's eve
we're talking about
especially with eagerness some people
have to celebrate of course with other
people like we do normally for new
year's
more on that coming up new tonight at
six o'clock live in the newsroom i'm
david charns 8 news now
all right thanks very much david